hello hello hello we just had to restart
because Simmons cursed and Josh got
upset didn't like it we've never heard
that word on the internet we have but we
can't do it in the first three words of
the podcast give the Jersey state bird
to the listeners out there no you cannot
Wow that's not allowed that's a shame
don't change the channel
stay on Sims and let go end of the
episode a nice 20 minute 25 minute
conversation with Killa cam our senior
NBA lead analyst and senior lead NBA
analyst one of those two Cam'ron is back
Simms asked him a bunch of really
enjoyable questions I thought about it
is it do you like having women and
marijuana in the studio I never thought
about that and then we talked about the
NBA Finals a little little warning
though I did say that the Warriors
Rockets game felt inevitable and then
the Rockets won last night I mean I know
I'm happy I'm happy
it gives me oh I fell asleep at the end
I missed the end I couldn't believe I
know it's the second time this year
that's happened to me
happen to me the national championship
game - man I woke up and Nick Saban was
running off the field but that's why you
got to have the BR app where all the
highlights are in case you fall asleep
for you so we so that's coming up at the
end josh is back we did not announce
what our mascot battle is gonna be but
we figured it out over text today yeah
you are gonna be at the end of the power
of the middle when we talked to Phil
Simms a panther yes and I'm a Jaguar
yeah and I'm quite excited it's rather
interesting that last week's defending
champion was not invited back to defend
his title it was a pity party your d-h
I'm happy to retire and if you don't
show up on Mondays you're not a regular
on Wednesday mascot but there wasn't a
third cat to really go we're getting
closer to being a tag team like you
haven't picked the tag team yet but that
one's gonna be great so you might have
to pick a partner it might be you and
your dad versus me and Josh first thing
Lil Wayne Carter blew up yeah did we
talk about this on Monday comics
reaction I don't think we really I don't
even know if we did I don't think so
how did Kyle react to seeing tattoos and
an earring on his face and every like
dude is he like yo Sims the players
think I'm cooler now I mean he's woke to
the internet I think that that's the
first thing is he like you a little bit
yes very much on Twitter or Instagram no
the only thing he does tech nuttin
technologically sound is Drive a Tesla
and then that Tesla it's got that's
where he listens to us or maybe other
people or any podcasts that maybe I've
seen the inside setup of that okay
that's pretty cool but no everything
else I think he's pretty coolest as far
as technology his phone started blowing
up he was blown up and he and he sent me
the picture of the tattoos on his days
which I wanted to be like I sent that
picture to your wife that's why you have
sure but thank you very sending that
today and he's his big thing was what
was the statement he said it was
hilarious he was like this is the first
week I understand social media he's a
party Kyle I've never understood the
power of it he's like but between the 50
cent thing that he was a part of us and
then that being and what how it blew up
all of that I think his wife was the one
that was like yeah how did she feel
because I'm sure that to a lot of people
she didn't admit that Lil Wayne was the
reason that their kid's name was Carter
no he she the first the first thing she
sent to me was blonde woman emoji would
hand over her eyes like about the cup we
had released on social media so she was
like and I was like I'm sorry I was like
I hope you're not mad at this or
anything like that yeah I was like but I
think this is really good for Kyle to
it's gonna humanize him or something
like that oh no it's fine this is great
it's all true
and she was like especially about the
part of the ad DDJ you know because
that's the way he is almost did this is
a song we listened to her for 20 seconds
and he changes it man yeah I love it
Kyle favorite coach coaches owners teams
they're gonna have a long yes pattern
thank you pat him down it's like you
know what we need to do you're arguing
in 1994 superswift oh my gosh he was
like famous for sweating it's not that
hot in here woody
it's like 69 and he's sweating like I
just did a drug test I've been yelling
in walking around fight the last thing
that was it I mean you know who else is
sweating but the owners because this new
anthem policy is gonna fall right in
their laps I just came out we're doing
this Wednesday afternoon it just came
out and fentruck I'm curious can you run
through the new policy for the anthem
for the NFL so I have the policy
statement that you sent me earlier with
the six bullet points on what the owners
have agreed on so I'll just go through
these one by one starting with the first
one all team and league personnel on the
field shall stand and show respect for
the flag and the anthem alright so
that's pretty simple if you're on the
field the NFL is now requiring you to
stand yes to the game operations manual
but will be revised to remove the
requirement that all players be on the
field for the anthem and that was
installed because they had made a deal
with all the military to to prominently
feature the players and now they're
saying if you don't want to stand go
into the when I grew up watching my dad
play in those games there was very there
was a lot of times where they weren't on
the sidelines during the national anthem
they ran out after that and now it's a
part house because we gotta have jets
fly over and we get have a flag that's a
hundred yards long and all those things
yes number three personnel who choose
not to stand for the anthem may stay in
a locker room or in a similar location
off the field until after the anthem has
been performed self-explanatory for a
club will be fine by the league if its
personnel are on the field and do not
stand and show respect for the flag and
the anthem and a club will be fine by
the league that is interesting to me
well we'll get to that the end keep on
number five each club may develop its
own work rules consistent with the above
principles regarding its personnel who
do not stand and show respect for the
flag in the anthem okay at number six
the Commissioner will approach impose
appropriate discipline on League
personnel who do not stand and show
respect for the flag and the anthem so
that's where to me that's that's where
it gets taken out of the team fine thing
again it goes back to the player read
that last statement ago because I don't
think they're talking about players
there I think that's a leave personnel
person okay like if a referee took a
knee right all right yes you're right
anybody employed by the NFL League
office right okay go ahead so let me
hear your take on that all that Sims
poof gosh should I go first I mean I
let's just let's talk about it I don't
know I don't think I've wrapped my head
around it I mean I
like it first of all from the aspect of
how do you not involve the players in
the conversation the people that are
being most directly affected the people
who have the families that have had to
deal with these social and Justice's
again they're just gonna handicap them
without ever discussing it with the
NFLPA it said they presented it like it
was an agreement and then the NFLPA came
out and said we were never contacted so
the statement from Georgia Tala on
behalf of the NFLPA quote we we were not
consulted ahead of this meeting on any
potential changes to the anthem policy
if there are changes to the policy that
put the players in a position where they
could be disciplined or fined we are
gonna do what we always do fight
anything that encroaches on players
rights to the end so the discipline and
fine part there so they're basically
what they're hoping the teams are gonna
discipline and find play is the big
change the big change is that now it's
not going to be on Goodell yeah it's
gonna be on the individual owners to
figure out what the discipline will be
yes let me go through my big takeaways
here first thing I thought left
co-conspiracy and it fells adding
another thing that will be hotly debated
in the CBA agreement in 2021 to distract
the players from trying to get the
ultimate goal exactly right so that was
the question Neal for the anthem if you
take 900 million less second thing I
thought was okay let me try and
understand where the NFL is coming from
Roger Goodell got thrown into the fire
against the President of the United
States and had to come up with a
solution and on its face it makes sense
to me your issue and I think what a lot
of people's issue is they should be able
to do whatever they want but Roger
Goodell is trying to run a
billion-dollar business if you want a
protest stay inside but we're telling
you that you have to stand and from just
a business perspective I do get it I do
too now this is where it gets very dicey
because every cause has an effect and my
issue here is this when a player is
kneeling on the field they are
surrounded by 60 up or 52 other players
and coaching staff and they are
separated for the field and from the
fans and when it is over they are
protected now the visual that we will
focus on as football fans is a camera
directed at the tunnel who didn't want
to come out before it was we can focus
on the kneelers but they're kind of
protected the closest that a player is
to a fan is when they're going through
the tunnel so now when like the Michael
Bennett's of the world and all those
guys are coming through the tunnel
they're gonna be surrounded by all of
the fans and now it will be Adelaide boo
and reaction to them that was the first
thing I thought of that would be an
image of week one will be which players
are coming out of the tunnel I don't
think that's gonna ever happen now what
do you know I just don't think it's ever
gonna be segmented like that you're
either gonna see like a team that's out
there from the anthem and they're all
standing or there's gonna be like if the
team I think gets the sense that okay we
have like 20 guys that might not come
out and then that the other forty guys
you're gonna go out there I think
they're gonna realize that's not gonna
look good it's gonna cause controversy
and it happens to the guys that say I
want to be out there
I know Alejandro Villanueva I don't know
but they're right the problem when you
decide to take a side on this you're
alienating somebody no matter what side
if you stand for the just everybody stay
inside you're alienating the people that
want to be patriotic and go out there no
matter if they sign it or not I guess
what I want to say is that like they've
actually put a magnifying glass on this
I know like why why what why do you have
to feel like you have to be out there
but okay
okay I get it I mean I like hatred I'm
all for the country I learned this from
all or nothing yes your former
quarterback in the Tampa Bay Bucs
organization Jason Guerin he said the
way that I've always done it the way
that I've been taught the way that I
teach is your toes are on that white
line and you stand for that flag the NFL
is very military base come with a strong
American history like tradition right
and they I know it's just clear to me
the people that want people to stand do
not understand why people are kneeling
and the people that are kneeling do not
understand why people are so attached to
this people that the first group of
people you said that
how'd you phrase that the people that
don't understand why people are kneeling
yet they yeah that group right there yet
they're uninformed they're clueless I
don't know what to tell them they're not
in it they're not kneeling for
disrespect to the country they're
kneeling for the same thing that's going
on again this offseason that's going on
last saw season which is you know social
and justices of people being wrongly
arrested once again cases all throughout
the news all over the country that's why
they're kneeling but this certain group
of our country has made it oh it's all
about disrespect of our country when I
don't know I've been at other sporting
events whether it's mr. Trump's NASCAR
or not I've seen very disrespectful
people drinking beers why the national
anthem is going on or not paying
attention so I just I'm sick of the
double standard understand today's the
thing that I think that this is really
creating though other than attention on
the tunnel is it's taking the ball out
of it's changing the battle from
commissioner and player and it's making
it owner and player and I've always been
told the reason Roger Goodell has paid
50 million dollars a year is because
he's supposed to take the brunt of
public consciousness sure instead of the
owners he's supposed to protect them we
are going to learn a lot about these
owners we've learned a lot about these
owners these last few months remember I
tracked every public reaction by every
owner and people like Bob McNair
compared to somebody like Jeff Lori we
saw where they stood yeah Jed York was
very for the players
the Cincinnati Browns and mr. Brown's
since ie Bengals and mr. Brown said get
out there and stand yeah so we're going
to learn a lot more about the owners and
I don't think the owners are as publicly
savvy as the Commissioner and these
owners it's funny we talked about how
the players are replaceable I'm starting
to believe that these owners are very
replaceable - oh you mean just another
rich white man with a bunch of zeros on
their bank I think that there are I
think there are more I think there are
just as many if not more people with
three commas in their bank account then
there are superstars in the NFL I think
it's harder to find a superstar NFL
player than it is to find a billionaire
when Donald sterling went down they had
owners clamoring to get it Carolina
Panthers everybody's coming out of the
woodwork to get a team so I think that
we could see the owners truly start
revealing their ID
and it could cost them a lot of money in
the long run to their own personal
businesses and the teams and people like
Bob McNair I wonder if it starts
impacting free agencies I know the only
problem is is there's only so much money
to go around no idea people don't want
to play for Bob McNair you know I like
I've told you people are disappointed in
New England about Belichick in his
stance there but those things but
there's gonna be no choice to the
players that's that's what's happens in
the NFL they have no choice there's only
32 teams there's only so many safety
positions and tackle positions and
quarterback positions right and if guys
want to get paid or make money again I
think this is the other thing - the
national anthem issue the kneeling it's
not good the players are not gonna win
that battle as much as I think it's you
know it's for the right cause and we all
know what it's for it's not gonna win in
the court of public opinion not right
now in this day and age with the state
of our country and our president and the
way he is and I just think that's why I
don't even I hate the fact that they're
doing this because they don't talk to
the players but like I said last year
the kneeling has to stop it has to I
if I'm really gonna call myself the
players podcast and we're for the
players as much as I know the fight is
real and we want to continue to fight
for this I think at the same time the
tracking from the real message and it's
really only gonna get make it more
divided and it's gonna hurt the sport
but she's gonna hurt the players bank
accounts and things like that and that's
where I get worried about I think that
there are a few teams where we're gonna
learn a lot like a team like the Texans
we're gonna learn about the relationship
between owner and the players and really
if the players can take a stand against
the money and all that the other team
though is the Eagles yeah and Josh
actually had a pretty good theory about
this what were you telling me outside I
just said that if the if it's on the
league to find the team if their players
are out on the field and not standing
for the national anthem then an owner
like Jeffrey Loria could just stand up
and say players do whatever you want
sure I got your back
find me and I'll pay for it and now and
now it becomes an NFL versus the owner
thing what is that do we know the fine
state knows a fine that's what Adam was
saying before
lump-sum and ten people citizen
escalated asking each guy
really if roger goodell starts punishing
the owners remember when roger goodell
first started one of the knocks against
them was your punishment seem arbitrary
it's still a knock against him you give
two games here you give eight games
there it doesn't make sense
but the owners are kind of okay because
it's their players when it's them
remember they elect Roger Goodell I
think Roger is being put into a really
tough spot now it's it's a lot like our
government he wants it to be federal and
now it's going to the states and when
you start having to punish the states
when you have to start punishing the
owners your relationship will start to
get frayed we are not going to know the
true impact of this until the preseason
and until week one and then two but
what's interesting now is I don't know
what put choice to the pliers have I
just I don't I don't know what they're
gonna say I'm excited to go outside no
ones that really want to make a message
whether that's Michael Thomas the safety
that was on the Dolphins we don't know
if Erik Reed's gonna get a team captain
we'll see how far they want to go
Michael Bennett Chris long member
Malcolm Jenkins had the fist up in the
air they want to fight for something
where the players podcast and we support
them it's just very interesting to me
that this is truly an epidemic not an
epidemic this is going to be a situation
that is exacerbated because of the media
when the cameras are on the tunnel when
the camera we are the ones that are
making this a conversation yeah and the
eyes will be on that we're gonna judge
on how it guys know I know but see the
conversation was going somewhere again
I'm until mr. president got involved I'm
just saying it was going somewhere it
was dying out it was not a knob a
subject until he got involved and yeah
yeah that's that's it that's what he
does okay so one guy that has supported
Trump is Robert Kraft and you texted me
and said you see Robert Kraft comments
about Tom Brady it's clear that he's
been talking to Tom Brady right he came
out and kind of said guys don't worry
said that Brady will be back in minicamp
in June and you went so Kraft and Brady
are talking yeah they're talking my
conspiracy theory maybe right yeah yeah
I think you're there's a lot of things
that are probably right in your
conspiracy theory yeah I know that Bill
Belichick said Robert I want to move on
to Kvapil yes and then craft
that brady boy not gonna move all the
girls are so cute Tommy but yeah I mean
that's the store again it's the story I
get in New England I haven't got all the
facts all that but the thing I continue
to hear is that yeah basically that I
think Belichick thought Garoppolo for
the future let's see if we can make
Brady this be the last year for Brady
Brady got wind to that and that's where
Garoppolo got ended up getting pushed
out of the building but yeah what does
that show me today is there's no
communication going on between probably
bill and Tom here Tom mr. Kraft is
reaching out the time to go what are you
gonna do this OTAs when he gonna come
around oh the mandatory minicamp that's
mandatory I'll be there for that it is a
big deal I mean it's New England they
want their guys there we know that their
machines everything's detailed this is
making me sympathy for Belichick I can't
imagine being the middleman between the
star quarterback and the owner and I
mean Belichick is kind of being rendered
powerless in this entire situation
here's a guy that had complete control
over who was on the team and how they
played in what position and now he's
being undermined at his star position I
mean the fame of their relationship is
the local high school quarterback could
throw that Tom and that's how he was
able to rule with an iron fist and
everyone listened right and he's kind of
been emasculated by his own owner yeah I
agree but it's the way it's like what
Jonathan Kraft came out last year you
know not long after the Garoppolo trade
right what was his comment Tom Brady's
earned the right to stay here as long as
he wants Bill Belichick probably doesn't
look at it that way he's running a
performance based business that's I want
to win every year and he's going oh okay
so he's we're gonna have Brady until
he's 47 and he's like a in a wheelchair
and we were just gonna he deserves it he
did so much for us no he's thinking
about the future and the betterment of
the franchise and that's why he wants to
make those cutthroat decisions which
what you have to do in every business I
would ask people out there that are
siding with Brady and Kraft one question
who is gonna act out of a motion first
Kraft Brady or Belichick not Belichick
not Belichick three and my question for
everyone out there is our business is
better when you act with emotion or with
fact with fact
the Patriots Empire is crumbling because
of a motion and the only emotion I see
is this father-son weird relationship
between Kraft and Brady I will side with
Belichick until everything ends
I mean Brady's the best coach we've ever
seen yes we got an in their prime by the
way I saw this on like reddit on our
reddit page in their prime Vince
Lombardi Bill Belichick why don't we ask
Phil Simms why don't we call Phil bum on
the horn what's your take I mean to me
it's Bill all the way really all the way
it's hard cuz it's like how do you
compare Johnny Unitas and Peyton Manning
right I know I get that it is hard but I
just think the league has become bigger
business there's more players involved
there's more college football involved
the rules are set up for it to all be
even and he just continues to dominate
it I mean obviously Lombardi's a huge
deal and the man I know that but I just
think with all the different elements
that are involved in this game today man
I just and the rules being set up for we
want things to be even and we want
different teams in the Super Bowl and
yet one team is always in it I got to
give him the ultimate respect big phil
simms
well let's see what time it is oh you
guys are almost done time only 10
minutes late that's awesome hey future
Hall of Famer big Phil I have a question
for you and what is that question there
mister Adam not go in their prime better
coach Vince Lombardi or Bill Belichick
Oh Bill Belichick nice so you agree with
your son yes even though well you know
they both have one thing in common they
were both tremendous innovators in other
words they stayed a step ahead of
everybody else
yes and Vince Lombardi did it with
training the way he treated players the
way he broke down plays that where the
NFL wasn't really doing that at the time
when he was having great success in
Green Bay did you know these things I
did yes I did that cuz it yeah I did I
mean this is your son speaking I mean
you know
me I've watched nine million New York
the history of the New York Giants and
things like that and that's where the 50
Giants were really good because guys
like Landry and Lombardi who were the
offenses and defensive coordinators were
watching film and doing in-depth
analysis before the rest of the league
so yes I did know very very good he ate
whatever the contest is today Adam
Christopher is gonna win is that the
coaches would say here's the play and
you blocked this guy and well coach what
if the guy who lines up and he's not
there don't worry he'll line up right
here and so the guys you block if you're
the tackle could be able to Center well
she'd have to somehow have to go they're
still blocking and Vince Lombardi kind
of started it saying hey let's have a
lineman talk changed the play you do
this I do your job and that's really the
essence of the greatness of the Green
Bay suite then I heard so much about
that they blocked it a hundred different
ways even though everybody said all
there's a famous Green Bay suite but
what they did with it was so like you
said analytical or whatever or so smart
and so compromising that it led them to
many titles an official party dad I
don't think I've ever asked you this
question when you were playing in the I
mean I know your coach was awesome and
we know Bill I mean Bill Parcells was
the man I'm just saying but out of the
guys you played against in football who
do you think was the most innovative guy
you went against in your career in there
79 through 93 oh that's easy
there was two guys they you know I've
always not wanted to do this because you
know I'm always talking about sports and
there's some people at CBS I used to
work with he goes man we should do a
show on your you know in a spike so to
answer your question for the out of
doubt buddy Ryan
okay you're not expecting that okay go
ahead
well no cuz that face to face buddy
whines defense and going oh my god
so every rule that you had as an offense
in the NFL you know it nothing held up
against the Chicago Bears defense
because the way they lined up in the
positions they were in and of course
they a great talent but yes they a great
talent but they had a great scheme and
it's unbelievably just won one Super
Bowl with what they did what they had
and what they did right that's one thing
but the other one of course is and
people debate this and I think even Bill
Belichick gave me a sermon on it you
know about the West Coast offense and
Bill wall scene you know what's drove
the swing pass to the running back
instead of hands off and go on a sweet
right and make it easier so his
philosophy on the pass game and all that
I think to this day you know we still
see a lot of the signs of it just like
buddy rise defense to a degree is still
in the league not the same but you know
just to talk about Bill Walsh yeah I
worked out you know you've heard this
story Christopher when I was in college
I don't know how many teams I had come
down to Morehead State working on I'm
gonna say 20 right and everybody said
the same thing every coach get a lot of
receivers how do you want one one we do
coach throw it as hard as you can
just throw it we want to see you throw
it okay I can do that I'll just throw it
and you know the poor guys I'm just
beating them up and running curled out
some smash them in the head with the
footballs I've thrown so hard and then
Bill Walsh comes in and he's wearing a
white sweat suit and you know you can
see his finger under his chin how you
did yeah right and I'm back there
dropping back to him bullet just no no
no no don't do that to this you know be
more this you just be more graceful
throw it softer and he's doing this
voice I call it softer because come on
try to be pretty and I'm just going what
is wrong with this dish and but as the
workout progresses I really get the hang
of it and I mean I'm throwing the ball
because all that's so pretty
Oh beautiful pretty and then we get done
with the workout and he says to me all
right
we're going to
traps you and you're going to lead the
NFL in passing as a rookie next year and
when once we draft you I want you in San
Francisco the following day because go
to get the work I'm making you the
leading passer and football year rookie
year and I guess I must have made a face
and he goes you don't believe me and I
said oh yeah I know I believe you and
then he went he rattles off like six
quarterbacks that led their guy Benjamin
whoever else there was a steep hill at
Stanford I think they led the nation in
pass in he of course Ken Anderson
Virgil Carter Greg cook Virgil Carter
couldn't throw it 15 feet and he was
like the leading passer in the NFL
because they designed this offense well
if you can't throw a deep bow it's short
right and so those are two guys that
really come to my mind about that and of
course what's the other great innovator
or the God to change the NFL I was gonna
die bother going on I thought you're
gonna say Joe Gibbs but well tell Gibbs
did a lot of great things but and you
know even on defense they were kind of
crazy but pretty credible right but the
movement the shifting all that was one
thing but of course Lawrence Taylor
changed pro football to you guys other
one right on a scrimmage so they could
give the the tackle a little more help
to block Lawrence one-on-one well it
used to be all in linebacker the guard
to pull out and block the linebacker
that's how everybody did it right and
all of a sudden the guard pulls out and
Lawrence's already run by him and kill
the quarterback and it took a while for
everybody to adjust to it they fo the
owns always slide out and let the tackle
to a team in the guard you know so on so
that was those are some that just jump
off the Vince Lombardi buddy run Bill
Walsh Lawrence Taylor I'm missing one
that always talks about can't think of
well I have a scouting report for you so
we had our our good friend an mba
analyst cameron coming yesterday a great
rapper from the new york new jersey area
and he pasted Fenric in ping-pong and in
Fenric beat him in three sets
and federic intimidated him by bringing
out his own paddle and I just want to
give you that information
oh that's interesting what do you mean
he didn't beat him in three sets three
it was I mean it was nothing special
means vendrick I'm not trying to play
down his skills he has skills he's gonna
be a good match for you but Cameron was
like you know it was like summer league
basketball it wasn't really a legit
match up you know I saw my ping-pong
table the base you know I might unfold
that thing and start working a little
bit clean it up but I do have my own
panel and and I just found it in the
closet
in fact I am about horrible that are all
perfect so and you know I got to get
sharp because I got to keep my streak
going against at least my children well
they can't beat me so the morale Day
weekend yeah do you play with a sponge
paddle or pimp's you play with sponge or
pips does your paddle have the little
dots on it or is it just one felt no
more English on it and you can just turn
it over and slam it at will that's
what's great about it ya know we had
somebody we had somebody reached out to
the podcast and say that them and 10
other friends from London want to fly in
for the draft party that's going to be
at your house and everyone everyone is
asking if before we do the draft party
if the undercard could be fill versus
Josh in ping-pong well like a pressure I
made this trip three daughters okay
don't worry it's gonna happen it's gonna
be great are you ready so today's battle
Phil your son is going to be a panther
and I'm going to be a Jaguar since
you've already
own your cards and given the wind to
Chris no no first you're going first
alright Phil I am a drag wanna sell you
know you know that was you was that you
rattle yes it was doing that I mean did
you do that like with your girlfriend do
you growl is that what you're jealous
hey Phil I'm not gonna get risk adding
report on that no could you do that one
more time no I can't
[Laughter]
so I'd like to State for the kid for the
court here and for you honorable Phil
Simms that Jaguars are the third largest
cats after tigers and lions weighing up
to 350 pounds I know that the Sims like
size they are considerably more muscular
and strong whereas other cats we have
like 200 they're at 350 Jaguars are
incredible swimmers so if my opponent
here tries to go on land or on sea I am
fine and Jaguars are famous for hunting
solo pound two bound pound to pound a
Jaguar will kill anything that moves
they have a better bite force than any
other cat as well as any other mammal I
have a little bit more argument but I'd
like to turn it over to Chris I just
wanted to give you an appetizer
sometimes go too long so I'm gonna slow
down why so you can talk about you why
don't you try and go mr. panther I mean
that's some bets of BS first of all I'm
a panther I'm a black panther have you
seen the Carolina Panthers things bring
racing no he's just black I'm just
stating the color of it and I'm the same
animal as you actually are I know but
I'm all over the world I'm in South
America and then I'm also in Africa and
Asia so I'm just your I'm a little more
well-traveled and smarter than you I can
survive on different continents Gurley
in that little South America corner
sorry I can swim too I can climb trees
our measurables are all the same I'm
just a smarter animal Othello you had
your turn
shut your big mouth you're gonna so
you're the same animal first of all I'm
smarter there's no Jaguars you're
forgetting there's no you're the same as
me
you are the square to my rectangle a
panther is a Jaguar the Jaguar is the
kinda leopard but no your foot you're
messing this up now Jaguars are all of
the animals a panther is just one type
so technically I'm all of the animal I'm
all over the world your regional you are
the square to my rectangle not every
square is a rectangle you are only in
South America Jaguars aren't all of them
Panthers are the one that are regional
thank you for being a part of my animal
I didn't even finish yet no I did not
first of all and and your animal is dumb
because it shouldn't be in Florida he's
stupid yeah there's no Jaguars in
Florida yeah I guess the Panthers in
Carolina with their bathroom we have our
brethren here we didn't send up any of
the black ones here to North America
because guns are legal and we send up
the lighter he's distracting you Phil is
distract color the actual lion Panther
cuz he's a little lighter and we know
how Americans are jacket at the
Superbowl everywhere I am a black
panther cuz that's what the Carolina
Panther is I am of course harder to see
in the jungle or in Africa or in Asia
because I am black okay nighttime forget
about it you can't see me I am the most
stealth weapon on the planet while he's
so shook right now do you see his eyes
he's not he's already under yarn Phil
yep second good want me to say this
before I get out of your range I mean
deep from deep in my heart
you're both truly losers that's one
thing and I can't think of the name of
the series Les Stroud that is name the
guy that goes down builds himself out
the awesome rubber man the name for the
man versus wild man versus wild or
survivor man survivor man yeah man well
survivor made geared of nothing can do
everything but there was an episode he
was walking in dark and it was real and
you could tell by his face
the dead wire was following me tracking
it but was it a black hole no so I'm
going with the judge wow that's enough
for me but I'm a Jaguar so he's saying I
won he's saying he'd rather the black
ones scarier than your little creamsicle
one that's what he's saying no no black
Jaguar this is the Jaguar I was a
regular Jaguar that scared Survivorman
Phil seems future hall-of-famer
and the best judge I've ever had thank
you for this week when I go to church
this is enough when he said it was dark
I was like that's gonna be a black
panther in the forest yes I am know so a
panther is a Jaguar but a Jaguar is not
always a panther right Yeah right
which I'm not all Contin you were the
same thing I know he just likes me more
yes the real Sam I mean I think I at
least have brethren here in the country
the North American I don't like smart I
sent the lighter-skinned one up in the
country where the guns are legal and I
said yeah I will I will fully admit that
when you text me now and say what's my
animal I get a little nervous because I
was enjoying those first few weeks where
you totally forgot we were even doing it
and now you're looking up like what
countries of origin not ready for so I
love big Phil one thing that we've been
doing the show is ACL epidemic it
started because every year there's ACL
injuries and there's always articles
written that say it's an epidemic
sweeping the country and yet every year
it's the same amount of ACL injuries we
are up to three
it started with Fozzy Whittaker and then
yesterday
Paul Warlow a linebacker for the Eagles
tore his ACL
but the big name thus far tight-end
hunter Henry who really finished out the
year great for the Chargers they got rid
of Antonio Gates and they were ready to
move Foley on with Hunter Henry he tears
his ACL and it goes to kind of what
you've always said this time of the year
these guys aren't used to making cuts
right away and so you get these injuries
you do because too much you know the
training is the most important thing
like I am a big believer in the things
that these didn't happen this is where
we should have talked about my dad with
my dad to these things didn't happen
nearly as much in the old days because
in the old days it was all about no
we're just gonna work out we're gonna
lift away this time of year and cutting
you know to mandatory to mini camps that
was all you had but now it's like oh
they ran for a week they're good let's
practice they're in shape who cares
let's go it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter and then that's what happens and
it's just just this it's this boredom
from the coaches that's what OTAs is
that's it's the bull you've talked about
it with Gruden everything get in a do I
got a got in the field coach I don't
know what else to do what am I supposed
to sit in here and watch film all
offseason but I don't know this neither
of us are doctors but if hunter Henry
was cutting now or if he was cutting in
two months would that impact do you fall
shows that with within six weeks of
heavy training right lifting weights
ligaments and things like that gets
stronger so you're saying that if they
were to be doing more straight-ahead
movement and everything like that right
I think you would see less of these and
it's not I never want to criticize the
player right for not training like
instance they have off time - yes and
they and a lot of them are training
again you're not you can't always train
like hundred miles per hour balls to the
wall all year long right especially
coming off an NFL season where your body
has been beaten a crap first worst thing
would be is you actually tear ACL natl
in the facility right somewhere else
exactly so you ease your way into it
okay I'm running a little I'm lifting
weights and I'll continue to get
aggressive as we go along but it's
always pushed on let's get out there and
practice we got to do seven on seven cuz
man the quarterback and the receiver
they might not be able to throw and
catch this year I'm gonna admit that I'm
a little nervous about the Eagles
lost Paul Warlow the same day they cut
Michael Kendricks to save about six
seven million dollars this is on top of
the Timmy Jernigan and Brandon Graham
injuries everything is kind of getting
pushed under the rug because you have a
Super Bowl win carson wentz looked good
out there he looked good but there's a
lot of injuries where it was like man we
got Michael Bennett and Haloti Ngata on
top of all these guys and now I look at
the depth chart and go damn michael
bennett and hollow de nada are gonna
have to hold down the fort until
everybody else comes back right and the
weakness that I've always thought of the
Eagles was lying back yeah and then they
lost to yesterday right lost to
yesterday Jordan Hicks coming back from
a scene said he's gonna be I mean
Michael Kendricks I can't imagine even
if they call him up great in the Super
Bowl I mean he's got incredibly
something there something about seven
million dollars he's got incredible
physical ability I do Michael Kendricks
one of those guys I look at if he
latches on on the right team and the
right scheme he can be a difference
maker because there's not a lot of
middle linebackers that have his
physical ability we usually focus on
Kyle Shanahan like we did in the
beginning yeah you've got a lot of
former coaches and friends in the NFL I
got three things on Gruden OKs one's
funny Bruce Irvin commenting on Jon
Gruden said I've never seen a person's
face stay red for a whole seven periods
in practice is that accurate to what
you've experienced Ari cuz he's just in
practice this time of the year somebody
messes up almost on every play unless
it's just an offense that's totally
cohesive and together and been doing it
for a few years so he's gonna find
something on every play where agent ago
this guy guys a freaking dope doesn't
understand my protections yeah you
messed it up to whatever yes so that's
the way he stays I think the funniest
thing about Gruden is watching people
react to him so on ob melon Phan whoo
the guy that you love yeah it was up
like a month or two ago they were like
he's close to returning well like
yesterday after practice Cruden's like
he's not close to returning at all and
the quote was haven't seen much of OB
except in the training room which I grew
to one of those guys that's are all NFL
coaches guilting players in the training
room
it has Gruden better at it I would say
Gruden's better at it if Bruton is
better at it and he's really the big
thing is where coaches really get away
with it and you see it more than is you
guys they're always the young guys they
know they can pressure a little so
that's where it happens you know whether
it's the Kevin whites or the Devante
Parker's that we've heard Adam GaSe make
a little comments right it's always the
young guy who hasn't quite earned his
stripes and oh we think he might being a
little bit of a baby about this injury
so let me see if I can public pressure
nudge him out of this of course not but
of course not you know again most of
these coaches have never been athlete
worth a damn in their life they wouldn't
know what a pulled muscle feels like
because they're not strong enough or
fast enough to ever pull the muscle but
yet they're gonna judge people who are
not in the same body yet it's not right
and I read a whole article oh that's
where beljac ahead of the head of the
curve again it doesn't say anything
doesn't say so like wouldn't rush his
guy out there would go you know we'll
put you out there the first few weeks is
frickin OTAs ooh individual drills yeah
and then I see oh you're great at
individual joules and you've been doing
it for awhile go out to Pratt read this
a great article in the SPN about Mike
Tomlin and he's up he's he's a player's
coach in terms of players respect him
yeah but he's not babying the guys he
doesn't embarrass him in all this stuff
right uh one more Hackenberg to the
Raiders yeah everyone remembers when Jon
Gruden came out and said I would be
surprised that this guy doesn't go in
the first round you openly texted and
said look the guy can't evaluate
quarterback play Hackenberg I don't even
want to ask if there's a chance he can
play because I honor Cook was gonna be
the first-round pick it's all he said
Marie was like a first so yes I mean
Gruden Hackenberg Hackenberg I don't
think in this situation all I would say
is really just if you look at the
pictures of him on the internet from
today just look at the way that when
they show him throwing a football go
nobody throws like that nobody's bodies
in that position to ever throw a
football position he's like this like
his arms are like this with the ball
[ __ ] down both hands are going outwards
like it's it's he is not a natural throw
with the football
he is you're perfect of wow he looks
awesome coming in the room he's so
handsome and if man if he stood in front
of the podium who he'd be some face of
the franchise except for the fact that
he can't play in the field how much
longer Gruden gets a Gruden is not a
great quarterback evaluator him and i
know this is gonna be out there he's an
awesome off of an awesome offensive mind
that is going to just always collect
quarterbacks and then see what they got
and go oh wait this guy in person when
he runs my offense is better than I
thought or whatever it may be was the
Raiders the only team that would take a
chance because my question is how many
more times will someone go maybe I can
get through to hacking maybe one more
you think one maybe one more yes I think
it would be hard after this stint but
you might get one more dumb coach or GM
of my ball I like to miss freshman year
mmm at Penn State under Billy O'Brien
it's really a fascinating situation it
is and because once you get labeled like
that you get a lot of chances to I mean
all he's the first round talent it might
hurt though that on his way out he kind
of questioned the Jets coaching staff
and said they really didn't teach me
anything they never worked on my
throwing motion do you think Jon Jon
Gruden ain't gonna tell you how to throw
it I mean that's where it's it's where
I've told this right we've talked about
this there's nobody in football that can
teach you how to throw a football I mean
nobody I mean I know a lot there's
there's a few offensive coordinators and
quarterback coaches that know a little
but for the most part they have no clue
about teaching a guy how to throw a
football it's like the old Gary player
thing I'm not gonna take a lesson from
you unless you can come out in the
course and beat me you know most of
these quarterback coaches and offens
quarters weren't quarterbacks aren't
good throwers of anything any object so
oh yeah let me listen to you now because
you've gotten to so many classes and
shown me so much that you're willing to
learn
no they're just gonna teach guys the
offense that's what they're there for
here's the offense here's the read your
feet were cockeyed those are the things
they can stay on other than that they
can't really tell them the rhyme or
reason of why it's inaccurate or why
it's accurate it's very it's very
Elementary as far as that's concerned
which shocks people all right whoa big
offseason Chris I got three for you this
okay let's go give me three number one
number one Aaron Rodgers the dude's
already impressed with Jimmy Graham very
impressed quote the guy is pretty damn
talented he's got some different
elements we haven't had around here in a
while with his ability to read coverages
very quickly he catches everything with
his hands were pretty excited about yeah
I they should be I I think about
all the weapons that Aaron Rogers has
had and they tried to bring in Martellus
Bennett but Martellus our guy yeah
wasn't at that level of athleticism no
morning block any issues with his body
like he said no other guys he's had
richard rogers at titan they tried to
bring in Jared cook Jared Cook is a
athlete athlete but he's not at Jimmy
Graham's level wide receivers we've
always wanted him to have a bigger wide
receiver this I don't know if Aaron
Rodgers has had a guy like this
no Jordy Nelson in the beginning super
athlete Randall Cobb was never an elite
athlete Davante Adams might be the most
athletic guy he's had there I think so
and Jimmy Graham is at another level is
this a true whoa big offseason yes it is
actually I mean in the sense to a you
know I think we're forgetting about a
name people forget about a name that may
be one of the most dangerous targets
here right you're Michael Finley they're
what he was going that was when they
were they were dangerous because he
could expose that middle of the field
and his sentence he says right his
ability to read coverage is very quickly
yes this is a guy that's played with
Drew Brees and this is a guy that's
played with Russell Wilson yeah an
improviser right if Aaron and his tight
end can get on the same page Oh baby
same offenses as the two he was
previously in so that's gonna help out a
whole lot but yeah we're talking again
about the greatest physical specimen
we've ever seen at the quarterback
position as just far as his skillset
throwing moving different delivery you
know quick release whatever it is and
Jimmy Graham is one of the backs best
specimens we've ever seen the tight end
position he is now Jimmy Graham is not a
great blocker but they didn't bring them
up there to block not worry about that
and they haven't had a run game up there
ever so it doesn't really matter but the
big thing is is yeah I mean they're
gonna split out Jimmy Graham and we're
talking about one of the greatest
one-on-one throwers in the history of
the sport throwing to him and Jimmy
Graham like I know I've said to you
before and I think I've said it on the
podcast before people just don't realize
how big he is he is bigger than Rob
Gronkowski he's bigger than Gronk I
realized when we went to Seattle camp I
was blown away exactly he's a giant of
man I mean I've never seen that big know
at that position to be able to move that
the way he does so fluidly motion it's
phenomenal you're right and you're right
I mean he's got some set of legs
Isana he's just not as good a blocker
he's gone kaske but man he is special in
the past game but that was a whoa big
offseason that I actually thought was a
whoa because when I read the reading of
defense as I thought
I don't you're writing since chair
Michael he hasn't been able to own the
field no like Richard Rodgers is not
that guy nobody's nobody's really been
that guy and then again we talk about
hey this year whoa big offseason they've
all we're gonna go back and start from
scratch
play ball right so they didn't make the
playoffs all these issues okay so now
we're gonna change and tweak some
offense it's gonna be a better offense
but you're gonna have a I don't know you
know wanted to say a polarizing guy in
the offense for the first time in a
while to wear defenses are actually
gonna go damn we might have to do some
coverages and some things we don't want
to really do against Aaron Rodgers and
that might leave Davante Adams in
favorable positions moremore Rodgers
needs he just needs a little bit the
more and more I think about Davante
Adams could have a monster you yes I
would not I would think he is gonna be
the biggest benefactor out of this yeah
the thing is is he's been balling ever
since he came in the league he has like
I think that it was a I think he kind of
started slower he had some injuries so
the excitement wasn't there we just
didn't I don't think he grasped the
offense right away as soon as Jordan yes
he's been bawling yeah all right next
one offseason we see it every year
players working out with former greats
and we pretend that this greatness will
Tran to rub off on him cuz they bench
press together second year Cardinals
wide receiver Chad Williams yes has been
working out with Chad Ochocinco this
offseason quote he actually took my mind
to another level he prepped my mind more
than he prepped my feet it was me and
Chad going at each other every day
now his rookie season was kind of lost
he had three catches in six games and he
admitted he was daunted by the playbook
and the schedule but working out with
Ojo cinco whoa big offseason have you
seen players work out with former greats
and it actually had a positive impact
definitely yes I mean there's been the
guys that go down and work with Chris
Carter at the wide receiver position all
those things there's things to be gained
there especially a wide receiver again
two wide receivers another one of those
positions like we talked about with
quarterback where we talked about
technique in this there's not a lot of
guys that actually know techniques of
how to run certain routes as a wide
receiver in the NFL Oh show guys work
out with your dad I forgot exactly so
but yeah wide receiver I feel like you
can learn the secret weight a whole
little the way to sell your brakes how
to think about just the foot place and
sometimes you go sometimes just the
mentality of the mechanic is actually
all you need hey how about this thought
right like just for an example
I ran the 510 5 and the combine the one
of the keys to the 510 5 is when you're
coming up to the line and you're about
three steps away actually start thinking
about going the other way so then you
hit the line you're actually already
turned and facing the line you don't
waste movements so that's just an
example but I am find the Ochocinco
mental thing to because well that's
where people miss out on it a little bit
and they don't again we've talked about
this what makes players great yes well
the intensity Odell Beckham jr. shows
off the field is the way he is on the
field so it makes him great Lawrence
Taylor or whatever it may don't show a
guy you would want to learn from yeah Oh
Cho has a mindset of I'm the man I'm a
baller I don't care what you're gonna do
I'm gonna come out here and the lights
are on and I'm gonna show up and I know
New England it didn't work out the right
way but there was a mindset there that
made him successful in the early parts
of his career with Cincinnati and then
whether that be Chris quarter or really
any of the greats you've ever been
around they do have something special
about how they approach the game not
only their confidence in their self the
things they fear that might make them
work harder all of it plays into you
being a successful football player I
mean yeah I was I was I was a fear-based
guy some days it got me up in the
morning damn I need to get there I want
to be the first quarterback there I
don't want anybody stealing my job damn
I gotta put in the work I mean just you
know who knows who's out there I mean
that's kind of it drove me but I feel
like that I feel like if you work out
with Ochocinco you have two options you
either think he's crazy and you go away
from him or you embrace it and you
embrace some of that on the best to ever
do it think about Antonio Brown when he
was
hurt at the end of the season he went
and worked out with Chad Ochocinco
memory and they were but it Oh Joe Cinco
said he's working out with the greatest
feat of all time whatever and he was Joe
Cinco and tio or two guys that are still
incredibly athletic
I mean tio is still thinks he can come
back he's going into the Hall of Fame in
August at 44 years old yeah and the
reason I think that's still a story yeah
is cuz when you look at him you think he
can do you think he can do it I know do
you think he can do it no absolutely
notice who would be a better wide
receiver right now yeah tio or Dez
Bryant Dez Bryant okay all right so
they'd like to know it's okay I got you
but though I hear you because I've
actually had friends that text me too
and tio said all this stuff why can't I
throw him in the slot on like a five
yard slant and just see him bump
something yeah I know and like again I
think if all things were perfect on
every play he could have value in the
NFL like his top-end speed I bet you is
still pretty good it's probably better
than some receivers in the end what
happens if it's not but that's the
problem see to me this is where when
being around old receivers or old
players and I got to see Randy boss in
Tennessee towards the end of his career
it's the the twitchiness and the
explosiveness that goes away and then oh
[ __ ] Aqib Talib 'he's a foot in front of
me and he's twitching and explosive as
hell and now I need to get twitching
explosive and I need to be able to be
quick as hell quick as hell twitchy to
shake them and then have quick as hell
hands to get his hands off of me and
then have an explosive element to go
within three steps I can get around this
guy no that's what all of those guys
always miss it's that's what ends up
happening at the end of the day it's
just those little movements that make a
big difference against NFL starting
corners the reason I think this is still
a thing yeah and it's it's kind of it's
messed up tío never got closure
jeno would have played two or three more
years five or six years ago but no one
signed him because they deemed him as
too much of a troublemaker yes same
thing with Ochocinco Ojo cinco's came
when he was in miami and at that
domestic violence charge and it I don't
know if it was a charger not he was in
Adam
violent situation yeah that cut right
and they were both guys that were going
from team to team they went to
Cincinnati and T oh I think could have
played five or six years ago for two or
three more yes and he's kept himself
ready to play he has and it's always not
been able and I just don't think he's
gotten closure and those are the guys
we've talked about it before you suffer
a death your plate like the athletic
side of you dies but for you you kind of
went you know what I just it's just not
gonna happen
yeah tio never got that chance yeah
right and and especially when I hear
stories that he's working out for for
Josh Rosen's pro day at Cleveland these
teams are still using him and to me it's
like it's a little unfair to the guy to
just kind of parade him out there and be
like what will do it but I know I wanted
to get closure
yet his of all the Hall of Fame speeches
Brian Dawkins will be magnanimous
Urlacher will be under it won't be that
great randy mosses will be funny ray
lewis's could be 45 minutes long
Tio's is the one that i don't know how
it's gonna go I told you I interviewed
Dennis Rodman last week and before I
interviewed him I rewatched his Hall of
Fame speech and the look on everyone's
face before it started was half
excitement and a half panic right what
is he going to say and he's apologizing
he's a little bit nervous but tio could
go up there and say I could still play
yeah like is he gonna call out people is
he gonna yell at people is he gonna be
excited see me thankful is he me
grateful is he could be humble I don't
know he's the wild card of that we could
use the wild card cuz he's he was vocal
about saying he's been cheated and he
should have been in already so I get all
that it could be a little Jordan
remember would you know he has closure
in the NFL nobody use you think I don't
think John Elway walked out on a Super
Bowl Jerome Bettis walk down in the
Super Bowl you're talking about five
people I know but do you think even they
were like I still could have played yeah
I mean I think Elway I mean I think
Elway messed up he shouldn't have
retired and he's stupid they would over
they could have won three in a row he
went too early he just didn't want to
deal with I think all the other stuff
that I went into being a pro still he
wanted to play he just was like damn I
just don't feel like doing the work in
between the week Peyton
but all for the sign so that means we're
talking again it's a very select few but
everybody else you're telling me the 99%
yes like them Chris Sims of the world
out there and now there's never closure
it's never it's always gonna bring us
the tear to my eye to go damn I didn't
really get to get my career to end the
way I wanted it or get it off the ground
the way I wanted whatever it may be
everybody's gonna feel that way to a
degree he's getting the ultimate closure
whether you like it or not
with Hall of Fame yeah I mean it does
seem like that to watch grown men cry at
the Hall of Fame yeah it's it's having
like a family member speak you see all
the fans that are there for you and then
when they show your bronzed bust it's
permanent
and that's me closure yeah I hope so and
I hope it is for him and of course it's
gonna be extra money into his bank
account now because money gets asked to
go to the signing cards things and all
that to have HOF you know 2018 on there
that's gonna drive up his price like
$100 per autograph which is great for
him good for him he deserves that yeah
but at the same time to not necessarily
sure he deserves closure just not sure
you know he's the he is the exact
example of the guy in the NFL who he's
really squeaky wheel at times and when
you're an awesome player you can get
away with that but then when those
skills decline people go I don't know if
I want to deal with the squeak enos of
that wheel and I just think that's what
happened and it might not be fair and I
get all that though but that's just kind
of the the bet he made for himself to
last whoa whoa big offseason rookie
hazing has begun and it's with your
former team ooh the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
but it's kind of a positive funny one
okay so Vita veía big-time draft pick
for the Tampa Bay Bucs is being asked to
do one thing by his position mate Gerald
McCoy Gerald's been around the block
we've seen this before
he's not getting taped to a goalpost
he's not getting his car engine taken
out the tires are still gonna be on his
car and that's what they should do that
except this is what vetova is gonna have
to do McCoy says quote I told him he has
to tell my children that he is Maui from
Moana when he introduces himself to my
kids this is his only rookie duty I'm
gonna give him no dinner none of that
make sure that when you introduce
yourself to my kids you are Maui no
questions asked my favorite part is he
continued to say you've got too many
kids around here you're gonna go work
parties you're gonna do birthday parties
and all of that so apparently for all of
the kids on the Tampa Bay Bucs if you
see the movie Moana then guy is Maui
yeah he's gonna have to show up you're
like ah Maui so for the rest of the
probably finds to the student and he
wears the yes no what do they call a
skirt I've never seen Moana yeah but
I've never seen it actually then you're
just you're laughing cuz you know who
the guy is I know the guy is he's gonna
have to go to all these children's
parties guys that's a good one I like
that's fun fun's fun spirited see that
just like rookie hazing I like it you're
a fan yeah I think it's a necessary evil
in the NFL other than like making
rookies pay $30,000 for a dinner that's
the part where I think it's stupid
that's the Creator come on I mean I
warned sup wouldn't have talked him I
mean it allowed me to bond with the
older players the fact that I had to
have skull on me cuz Warren Sapp said I
did all the time it made my relationship
with Warren better because he knew he
could abuse me and I could take it and I
was tough enough to do that and that
gave me respect with other veterans on
the team Sims isn't some silver spoon
brat he can be motherfucked by Warren
Sapp all day long it just it does foster
a kinship and and you kind of wonder why
can't you be brothers without like
intimidating or whatever but there is a
line too and I guess that's what happens
I think for me I'm I'm done I agree with
you I'm done with the $70,000 check
right I'm done with the someone buying a
thirty four thousand dollar bottle of
Dom right there are more creative ways
to bond that's not empty your page F
yeah yeah make the guy you know make the
rookies gonna wash my car every Tuesday
of the day I like things like that
they're awesome it's great that rookies
gonna hate it but he's also gonna get a
ton of respect and probably gonna get a
bunch of free stuff off of it too
because when he gets done washing the
car that that's gonna feel bad be like
hey Brooke you want to come to dinner
with us
speaking of money Zack Martin's not
going to OTAs levy on bells not going to
OT baby so but we'll wait instead
generally we won't go yes waiting for
mini camps and training camps and all
that stuff but Aaron Donald Payne oh man
his money or I was going no no so Aaron
Donnelly obviously not OTAs it's
rounders Marcus Peters part of the
reason they were concerned about Marcus
Peters is the man will openly say what
he says and they brought him in and he's
already talking for the LA Rams hey man
pay the man Peter said I mean you win
the MVP man come on now so they got this
new guy Peters comes in they go what are
you thinking usually people would go you
know I don't want to talk about other
people my place hey Aaron Donald what
are you talking about pay the man yes
and now you know how Marcus Peters is
gonna handle his contract next year but
what do you think about that the sassy
quarterback cornerback coming in and
just saying pay him love it love it and
really it's gonna he's gonna get love
throughout the team because of that he's
gonna get love through the coaches
through that your excel the coaches are
gonna love it cuz they don't care
they're not in charge of that like it
maybe Shawn McVeigh might be I wish you
didn't say that but like the defense of
Kuwait Phillips you met Kay that's how
you get the team on you you're sticking
up for players taking over Sean McVeigh
said came out and said I understand why
he's not here yeah like we need we have
it we have to figure it out yes that's
good I think again with the Shanahan's
and the mcveigh's of the world they just
have their you have a great way with
players and they understand the business
and they understand the unfairness of it
at times they don't word on fairness but
yeah I think they do and I think that's
gonna can you continue to give them
street cred on their team and in the
locker room because just saying a little
thing like that we understand or instead
of going we're all we gonna talk about
the players that are here like okay why
do we even cover New England that's all
I want to tell people why go like how
about don't go to New England and see if
let's let's see if bill changes like I
know he would love it I guess so I'd
have mr. crap wouldn't though that's
that's and that's where money talks
we'll see that would be interesting
right if the media really wanted to
the bill right you stopped going to
craft yeah and you say we're not gonna
listen to you until you make your coach
say things but that's not gonna I know I
know
all right so Cameron is coming up now
yeah we talked some hoops we talked some
hip-hop it was a really good
conversation on Monday Memorial Day we
are having a special hour-long it was
supposed to be ten minutes q be with BR
Peter King hour-long special with Peter
King Memorial Day I'm telling you it was
supposed to be twenty minutes we just
recorded it and he's just full of
stories from riding the bus with John
Madden to telling stories about Chris's
dad it was a really awesome podcast and
I hope you guys enjoy it but as always
thank you so much we love you very much
thank you for subscribing fill up that
comment section hit us up on social at
Sims and left go foursomes peace out
homies vendrick would say meaning and
the lef koe man says good night guys
were here throughout the entire whoa big
offseason and we'll holler at you soon
enjoy your Memorial Day weekend peace
people don't realize them and meat is
not easy for the body to process I
always see these guys that like Chipotle
you're like I'll have quadruple steak
and a chicken and they get nothing else
and I'm gonna damn you got a huge belly
so I don't think it's working
we need to reassess there you go yes so
we are here right now with cam cam ranh
and we're just talking about how spelt
you are I don't hear on the high area so
if you guys could hook up the IFB so
I'll just keep talking because I can
hear you guys but you're looking spell
how much how many pounds have you
dropped
yeah I put um it more like in the 15
range are you way are you a daily step
on the scale though yeah you are like in
the morning or in the night once every
three days okay
I was shooting a movie in October and B
they reshoots and March and I actually
what the Phoenix to start this process
because what's the movie rod follow him
on Instagram right we wrote a movie a
song it's like a drama thriller I like
to mix it with um I would like to say
tell me let's say give me the actors
unfaithful faithful mix with usual
suspects ah that's a good one sir
so we wrote that I funded it sex and
murder mystery we spent about a quarter
million dollars on it um and I'm waiting
for the edit to come back which should
be in another week or two then I'm gonna
go shop but I also friends did already
want to get it I don't want to say any
names yes other options out there but
that's what I've been doing
foster's you made music movies is it
similar is a similar like feeling to it
well the me honest movies are much more
difficult because you have to have maybe
anywhere man I'm talking about minimum
10 to 20 people on the same page
whereas music you go in the booth music
all I need is just me him we could just
do it again
he makes beats he's an engineer we do
the songs and it's done we mix from one
of a guy you need three people yeah
now you movies me at least 15 you got a
tour coming up to next month in June yep
where can people get tickets I want to
get all that out of the way
um so be honest I don't know right now
okay but if you go in East Coast West
Coast east coast we're going all over
but if you type in Dipset forever tour
I'm pretty sure you know where the
fontelle I've always been fascinated
with like the recording session right
like just what you see on TV it always
seems like it's you know you few of your
friends maybe some girls just first um I
can take yes like and then I mean people
were smoking weed I just want to know
like from a creative aspect like was
that something that you always felt like
that helped you is that something you
want to do or you better flowing when
your minds clear what what did I was in
my 20s I was every studio session that
was every day even in my early 30s now I
just want to get my work done so I don't
necessarily have a bunch of people in
lingering cuz I'll get distracted then
also what happened was studios at my
house now so I could I could go upstairs
to eat I can [ __ ] around write play
games and write go back downstairs when
you're paying for studio time somewhere
else you wanna you know you're staying
there your grind and you get comfortable
yeah but also like guys have rules like
I know Kendrick and what they're doing
there they have out like a sheet on the
wall if you're not family or like part
of this you're not in here and then it's
the other problem right now with studio
time is cell phones right you know you
drop a hot bar someone puts it on
snapchat or Instagram all of a sudden
you got to release that Nick's right cuz
the pressure I saw right well you know
to be honest even if you come out with
an album and I'm talking about the top
of the time so maybe even let's say
jay-z you you'll get a month because
it's so much content out yeah you know a
great album
in a month I don't talk about a great
album good there are albums today that I
see that don't even get a day exactly
it's crazy what do you mean a day so
like Drake's gonna have an album that
comes out in like a month right there's
gonna be other albums that are gonna
come out the same weekend yeah they
might not get a day of press you know J
Cole had an album that came out two
weeks ago the way that I look at the
success of an album is how often am i
listening to it after that like a month
later am I still putting on sizzurp am I
still taking it in because there's just
there's so much and there's so many
places to get it from the right it's it
wasn't like before like the wall or FYE
where you walked in and and you bought a
CD streamings telling me new songs to
listen to every day well I'm always
interested just because I'm I was like
this as a quarterback or an athlete like
who so like who's the best rapper in the
game right now like for you I know you
have respect a lot of them but like if
you just said man right now this guy's
the man he's the monic not including
that including Kim right I'm saying
who's that guy that you look at and just
a Meyer I'm a lot I mean though you took
my old-timer present no present like the
Drake's the Kendrick Lamar conversation
those kind of guys I want that right now
is between the two you just make it is
intrinsic remark yeah you know both of
them stay busy they both work you know
sometimes people get a wave and then
they'll get comfortable and then you
don't hear from you guys always working
yeah so I would put those to it they're
like my corporations right like they
have like everything is like a machine
right now with those guys
Drake is so meticulous and everything
like like if there's a picture with
Serena there's a reason there's a
picture with Serena going out like
everything has a motive that's crazy
the cat does Kanye enter your mind right
now I got a bone to pick with God
bothers me right now so yeah I mean yeah
he's a great musician but I just don't
know he's that mentally and the beats
are totally honest my personal opinion
yeah is childish gambino is sliding into
the thing Kanye named the conga Johnny
created guy right you know I really like
what Souders Gambino bring to the table
that last video
was wild this is America well wild to be
honest what happened was uh but this is
America I never really looked at too
much childish gambino after that video
came out I went back and checked it out
so that the last album was unbelievable
a bunch of all of his old stuff and he's
been very creative for years
I saw childish gambino a gov ball and I
love that album
redbone as a song you've definitely
heard before the whole albums great but
yeah his old stuff like the three
thousand five and all that's not he's
interesting because he was not accepted
by hip-hop culture very early on he's
one of those guys that was an actor and
was like a comedian and all that stuff I
saw him in stand-up comedy that's what
I'm saying and so for and tell me if I'm
wrong I think hip-hop is something that
a lot of people came raised in it and
then they branch out to those other
stuff he did it backwards and I think
for a lot of people they were like it
took like two or three albums for people
to take him seriously almost though I
just wasn't aware yes and a couple of
people told me about him but I went back
and I've been watching him for the last
week or so catching up on all the stuff
to gossip isn't the Internet amazing
dope all right so the reason he's here
he's our Sims enough Khalid NBA analyst
I was gonna come senior and be analyst
that's as they call him on CNN no he's
our senior NBA analyst I am I've been a
little disappointed I just feel like the
Warriors are kicking that ass and
Celtics Cavs is getting good let's start
off with that one we're recording this
on a Tuesday it's gonna come out
Wednesday but the game it's now 2 2
where are you LeBron drop 44 where are
we right now Cavs Celtics who do you
think is a better team I mean definitely
Boston to me is a better team greed but
um they're younger they're hungry I love
Brad Stevens but LeBron is just LeBron
you know to me that's just what it is
and if and to me the real difference
maker in the last two games is Kyle
Korver mm-hmm you know I mean he did it
he's neither on the ball last night a
tremendous job when Jalen Brown last
night defensively and I think he's the
difference in the last two games near
Boston hasn't been great on the road
against anybody you know I don't think
they won one playoff against the Sixers
I'm course Cleveland as LeBron and so on
and so forth but Boston does have two
home court advantage hmm and did you
stink on the road so I think when they
get back to Boston this is the touch for
Cleveland yeah yeah five is - right and
then LeBron even when he's there Oh -
LeBron was down one two three against
Golden State yeah when you know even
though draymond guy suspended for that
one game right B if I've never counted
LeBron out four game heats loss for game
I agree
my question is never about LeBron it's
about will he get help just enough to
get him over yet yeah like the junior
can he be consistent can you get more
from Korver and then those young guys
they got from the Lakers trade like you
know like Markson Clarkson and then uh
Nance Nance like Nance had a big play
last night and I was like man you just
need a few of those from him every game
right well you know what with the new
guys um tom lugar give him some some
confidence in it let me get some playing
time do you ever watch like just body
language and look at ty lue and like do
you think like what is do you think the
relationship is tyloo and lebron i think
i think it's a little bit respect there
but but LeBron ultimately is the last
word I feel like he's the coach like
absolutely I mean I think he's the coach
I'm a GM if you actually I was wondering
last night do you thik when it teams on
offense do you think LeBron picks that
music - I feel like he's that he's like
I really like to play - jay-z or not I
don't think LeBron like runs the team
but they battle LeBron certain
basketball that's what happens I mean
you could look at old things of like
Phil Jackson and Michael Jordan you go
out and watch like walkthroughs that
they had in the Utah Jazz Series
Michael's out on the floor go no you
need to be here you need you here so
it's basketball because like you said
yet Boston's the better team right but I
am one guy in basketball if it's not too
far off can just even it out like this
is what's amazing to me just why we're
talking about LeBron tyronn lue gets
done this is how like 44 points is
really like oh just another game it felt
normal
they didn't even ask tyronn lue about
him scoring 44 points and after the fact
and the press conference and you're
watching people realized after the fact
that they didn't ask and they kept going
you know we just said
and we never even asked them about
LeBrons : 44 which is an unreal domain
absolutely right used to eat I think um
I don't even feel like Michael was quite
like Michael's still number one to me
mom yeah but I don't know if Michael was
Weaver is bored with 44 12 and 10 like
like we would be more like man that was
awesome
LeBron is like something you're not
gonna see as far as his height his
weight his athletic yeah the specimen
the specimen that he is Michael joy was
scoring 40 or 50 points more finesse
LeBron a bully you damn I said he
doesn't have a shot at jump shot
Michael was just jumping through three
people they won right make him lay hung
up on the other side stuff it was just
unbelievable yeah as we as well last
night and I'm not discrediting LeBron a
little bit but you know he probably had
about 10 of 14 points or terry rozier
rights to I know
like a kitty
absolutely and I mean I give them more
to credit for making that adjustments
kind of what kind of like with uh
Houston did the stuff curry yes yeah
yeah when you got when you 68 260 70
pounds and somebody's 6-2 whose 185 oh
it's over yes it's over so basically
that's the difference for me Michael
Jordan just made it look great didn't
look these kids today or the younger
generations eight you're not gonna get
the over that Michael drew important to
the table might do to kids do it for now
yeah you know I'm saying and everybody
else an argument who's better LeBron or
Michael Jordan but without so people is
this and so I see anybody and I'm not
carrying counting bo Jackson the Deion
Sanders because those guys play baseball
football through college I'm talking
about somebody say look I'm just too
good for this I could come back when I
wanna play baseball you know I'm saying
cuz I'm up
Michael Jordan I was eight rings minimum
that's just my book because he took two
years old came back won three chips
right after winning three chips and then
that last year when the team broke up
they couldn't I had that same team again
you know they didn't want to pay Phil
Jackson and it seemed disassembled
sausage to me Michael Jordan I was a
train
and so what I did one of the barn to do
years ago it say Amen take a year from
play football because I think seriously
you know you seem like passing court
last May yeah yeah years ago I said
whoever was a receiver and when he was
twenty seven twenty eight years old how
fast he is how high he jumps i told he
is he he would probably be one of the
best receivers ever even though
basketball is his thing but it's like I
wanted to see him shot at yeah that is
the funny thing about LeBron is he's
such an amazing athlete that we've never
seen that we always want him to play
other sports just to show the athlete
that he is he couldn't play football
because after two games they're going in
his legs because my dream oh it's all of
our dream he's a tight end he's a wide
receiver he'd be incredible there's flag
football where him and Kevin Durant
during the lockout mérida and he was
incredible my thing about LeBron is
we've talked about this before the
evolution of his game his 44 points last
night when he would do that younger it
was all layups he has all dunks
definitely the game with a three last
night right his shadow age is so much
better and I also look at his
conditioning and his body and it's it's
really I feel like I've watched the guy
grow up where younger he was never out
of shape he was just LeBron but now he's
going 48 minutes dropping 44 points
directing the team catching those passes
I've just never seen a guy this not to
mentally play exactly right and I feel
like that was on purpose because I feel
like in this era of the Spurs resting
starters and LeBron not became a big
thing last year became a huge threat and
now I feel like this was the year of him
wanting to prove people wrong I don't
think so
what percentage chance my thing is not
because top yeah please I think he
didn't have a choice
it wasn't like they was the first place
this year and he realized like if I take
10 games off we're going on 10 exactly I
don't really think he had a choice I
think that if they was in first place
that had a four five six game gap yeah I
think he would have took some games oh
but the team yet no no I really nah yeah
you're right do you think he was working
out and thinking about
do you think he was like pumping a
little iron to be like I think he just
thinks about number 23 in red that's all
I think you think that no one that
exists currently not Durant not anybody
he is only looking at Jordan at this
point I think that's the only guy that's
in front of them I think everybody else
is in the rear view for me unless we get
into like the 7-footer conversation like
she will this is a different person I
think altogether but he used to have
animosity for Golden State
before Kevin Durant got there mm-hmm and
I think once Kevin Durant got that he
realizes just no one's gonna get mad at
him anymore for not meeting their
exactly you can really do first time
they play go to the state he took them
six games with no Kyrie or no Kevin none
they're both are should have been the
MVP and a losing team right second
season they got Matthew Dellavedova
right and who was the big galoot that
got traded to the Lakers the other one
that got the Mozgov yes so I just think
that um he had his I cuz you know the
waves too when they play go to stage
real aggressive with stuff definitely
very very aggressive but I just think
what's covering the rink got these like
what can you do I need to admit
something to I know that I think my six
are [ __ ] hate oh man and it's like I
don't even dislike any of the guys in
the team like I actually like them as
people and they're all super talented
but what for they stand for I root
against them in every game they play and
I'm gonna be rooting for Houston you
talked about this yesterday
it's beautiful basketball yeah hate all
of it I hate it I hate it to be totally
honest my perception and my opinion not
perception my opinions on the whole
Golden State thing is yeah if if a GM
did it I don't think people would be his
man I think so you're right you know
yeah because that the players are
picking winkles going their destiny
people like all you yes oh so you're
right when Pat Riley assembled the heat
they went wow what a job like that right
but with the Warriors we go these
selfish champion - right Jason rings
right
exactly so I just think that people are
more disappointed that the players are
choosing where they want to go as
opposed to look at TM or something if
you look at if you look at go to the
state and as everybody won't go to state
it's up for Kevin Durant was drafted
there yeah yeah
draymond Green as far as stuff comes
yeah so it isn't like they did it to
draft free agency they kept people
around you know you got the lake about
necessarily of the Lakers you got people
who team I didn't mean save Lakers
people changing their team around every
year even though and I'm agreeing with
you
it's the highest of the high free agency
going to go to the state but everybody
else's through draft picks you know I
have this argument all the time about go
to state it's like are they cheat and
then they got this person who got that
person like protein drafted these people
you know you can't be really mad at gold
in the state you got to almost be mad at
Kevin Durant and that's just what it
stands for in the general you know it
always makes me think of the Thunder to
when they had a Westbrook harden and
Durant damn but I'm saying but I don't
think it Serge Ibaka would you got and
after this year what you have is those
three guys are all being League MVPs but
that wouldn't happen if they all state
let me say you're right harden Westbrook
and Durant horrible likely when it this
year that's what do you like watching
Harden I like watch the heart and I
definitely think he's enjoyable this
year but I think he's gonna I mean Chris
Paul you think that's a walk it feels
like a walk to me you know what I just
did the hard and step back you know when
I was the first time I saw this year
about his dad of war
yeah but you do get to step sort of
layer huh
so he's taking a gather yeah taking two
steps so I was like he's he's a high
school basket of stream he shoots threes
he gets to the free-throw line but in
terms of like entertainment I don't find
him to be the most entertaining
basketball player like it's actually a
tough watch for me sometimes because
it's 12 free throws and then Janine D
dribbles like what was the stat they had
last game he dribbled more
than all the five starters on Golden
State yeah like people like dribbling we
love dribbling through the legs that
idea might still make people fall so it
is a little bit enjoy saying you think
dribbling is a cultural thing about
Stefan clay I would clay Thompson
doesn't even dribble ever ever yeah 30
30 37 point 70 points on 11 dribbles or
something crazy that's crazy
I am truly one that thinks and I'd like
to hear both do your opinions like I've
60 points Kevin Durant is hurting
himself big picture long run like I know
he's gonna have rings he's gonna he's
kind of retire but I think he's a little
somewhat irrelevant and the best player
in the NBA conversation at least in my
tape I hear people fighting for it III
he definitely deserves to be in it but
it's hard to fight for him when he
misses 18 games and they go 18 to no
without them so you don't even know his
value and I think that's always gonna
kind of come back to bite him in the ass
I don't know what you guys think I
didn't be interested to hear you agree
with that more for anything just like my
opinion is this as far as best players
to yang's yeah he's never gonna have to
sit at the table with Reggie Miller and
John Stockton and Charlie Charles
Barkley and Patrick Ewing and if you had
to go to that far because you know the
time when Gary Payton and call Malone
and somebody else went to the Laker yeah
and they didn't win they tried to get a
champion I was so depressing right and
then it wouldn't happen Barkley went to
Houston with the odd Drexler and this
all happened after their prom so it
isn't like these big threes haven't been
assembled before even though this is
almost like a big four that they have
and um in on Golden State so I was just
hard for me to go against it when if a
GM put it together it was cool but if
our is the best player to me when he
went a bust I guess who's the best play
for you LeBron yeah
kill the burnished
yeah yeah he's a tough matchup for
LeBron I mean his jump shot is gonna
make him a tough match he's one of the
that would be always my argument with
like even back to the Jordan
conversation could you Michael Jordan
played in an era that there was no Kevin
Durant or LeBron James in the league and
there is something to that no I don't
hold it against him he still dominated
his era but no one could stop it I don't
really think LeBron maybe LeBron
I don't think and I'm like Kevin
Durant's a good friend of mine but I
don't think that they'd that physicality
back there I know it we were growing up
I mean we would see Jordan get planted
in the first row Charles Barkley said
the other night when curry did a shimmy
they would know you said assume you
would never happen now Charles Oakley's
of the world of make sure you never did
that sure I guess some of that some of
the Citiz going on now as far as shim
you know Kevin Durant threes I don't
think they would allow him to play the
way he's playing the rules would so now
let me ask you the reverse of that
what if Jordan was raised in AAU with
these rules because the thing is is it's
like nature versus nurture it's the
human development LeBron was raised in
the AAU culture with the game called
this way Jordan was raised in like we
might not even hear of a guy from a
certain part of North Carolina and then
we're gonna beat the crap out of you
with the bad boy Pistons so if Jordan
was raised in the AAU now would he still
be Jordan I think he because I think
it'd be better if you ask me I'm told my
v-star the same joy yeah right I think
he'd be better because he found every
two seconds here the physicality he'd be
at the line or so I got a chance to
interview Dennis Rodman last week and we
hung out for like an hour and that man
has lived life holy [ __ ]
focus thought three times yeah he broke
his dick three times he told me the
story he said that somebody got very
excited and it hit at a hip bone and it
was blood and
yeah yeah I didn't I didn't know I was
gonna get like that that's too much okay
I was talking to you I was talking to
him about LeBron or Jordan and he said
that he has to go with Jordan because
he's just never seen anybody attack at
that level and he's never seen LeBron
attack at that level and that Jordan
would find a way to to not only get
around LeBrons athleticism but use it
somehow to his advantage
and he told the story of the one Phil
sit in Phil Seville Jackson brought him
over to the house to try and convince
him to leave the Spurs and come to the
Bulls and he said you know I really only
have one thing that I need you to do
Dennis and that's to go and apologize to
Scottie Pippen for when you threw him in
the stands last year it's bothering him
and Dennis went over to me was like I
apologize can we be on a team now and
they're like let's [ __ ] go and it was
just like Jordan and Pippen and Rodman
and to me that was the squad
like I know Kukoc and all those guys but
Rodman
I felt like had Jordans intensity and
that's the thing when we compared Jordan
LeBron that's not quantifiable it's not
statistics it's not measuring everyone
just goes LeBron had the fire I mean
Jordan had the fire and LeBron doesn't
have that fire yeah it's kind of what
the difference definitely the killer
instinct part of whatever it is Jordan
just said when it was three minutes left
in the game there's just Jordan you
never doubted you were like whoa Hill
they're down by ten it's gonna come down
to the last shot and Michael's gonna
have the ball I mean how how many games
does warriors Rockets go it's what is it
2-1
I think it's over that's my assessment
it's over for one that game to kind of
gave me a little hope hopefully Houston
you know they look really good I think
to be totally honest Game three it
looked like James Hart was at the club
the night before yeah you like the
little sluggers a bunch of open shots he
could have made he missed wide open
layups I don't think that's gonna happen
again 40 points is definitely not gonna
happen again but I like Houston at home
I don't think they're gonna win this
next game but if they don't it's pretty
much over but if they still want to go
to stay Houston has some quite a
vendor's again and I kind of like them
at home but I'm just not gonna go
so are you gonna say formally - yeah I'm
gonna go for it - warriors okay so maybe
Rockets take the next one for two and
then what about Cavs Celtics that's the
one right dad last the one I think this
who can steal a game or will nobody
steal again I think I think this is
gonna go to Boston big row seven in
Boston LeBron's had good moments and bad
moments emboss and LeBron breaks
everybody in Boston's heart III that's
what I would say - so we get for the
third time in a row worth lebron versus
the Warriors fourth is it really for his
eighth straight loss Hwanhee one - he
would lost three and here's Thor and
that's know this is where this is like
the rocky thing - it's almost like you
know they're definitely not one minute
champion what I just I mean that's what
I'm worried about is that for o im3 3-1
if they go to state beats Cleveland
again it'd be three Game three champ you
know I mean I mean more if all even
plays Golden State is giving a sweep I'm
gonna go for one cuz you're gonna give
LeBron LeBron gonna win Game three at
home in 15 games like shoots rocket
booster I really think not only that I
would think Kevin Durant really steps up
when it comes to LeBron so I think yeah
that's gonna kind of neutralize LeBron
yes and that's my thing about Kevin
Durant
if Kevin Durant went to the Warriors and
wasn't the best player on the team I'd
understand your argument he's the best
player on that team - I know we used the
best player I'm not even arguing that
I'm gonna go back to your draymond Green
argument cuz that's the good [ __ ]
Cameron is the man what was the name of
the website I don't know the name of the
website but if you google google Dipset
forever tour find out where you could go
see us or tour next month and it said
and do we know the name of the movie yet
it's called is it a crime damn is it a
cry I want to get all of the Sims and
left go fans to support is it a crime so
when that comes out I'll come back [ __ ]
yes NBA lead analyst you have to come we
have you under contract absolutely yeah
what we'll do is after this sri if I'm
invited I'm telling them I'm telling
myself you're always invited you don't
understand that we're gonna be more
prepared let's come back before the
championships talk about a date for you
guys alright thanks brother thank you
thanks man be good mattress [ __ ] I want